sono sempre entrato in scena con la mia
musica
credetemi usare con le mie parole mi
rimane molto difficile
buonasera è facile amare la musica e
quindi anche mio padre amava la musica
suonava in una banda questo è mio padre
quello che suona con lo strumento la che
lui chiamava la coniglio la ma ho
scoperto che in tutta la toscana
lo chiamavano la maniglia la alias
tricorno contro l'altro in di molle poi
nel rilievo anche il nonno materno il
padre e paterno ovviamente il nonno
materno che una volta un paesano mi
chiese sono tre familiari che a tuo
nonno gino vinti ma che è un immigrato
quello sono i tamburi la banda di
tamburini
noi non siamo tutti solo con quel nome
tamburino mio babbo che amava la musica
tutte le mattine alle sei e venti faceva
il calzolaio veniva il kavala mia
portava una casta di affollate è una
radio alle sei e venti con una
trasmissione radiofonica che si chiamava
forte fortissimo qualcuno di due se la
ricorderà dove trasmettevano
principalmente musica sinfonica e musica
cameristica come una bella violenza
l'altra violenza è quella di avermi
iscritto al conservatorio e quindi sono
andate quasi una l'olio e come tutti i
ragazzi escono dal conservatorio o poi
vanno a studiare l'orchestra la mia
prima apparizione in orchestra nessun
tradimento l'ho fatta
in quest'opera bellissima del cavallo di
faglia c è chi conosce un po il mondo
dell'opera lirica è un mondo molto
particolare mi ricordo che a una delle
prime recite il baritono esce dal
dall'opera così esce dal
dal palco al sipario che racconta il
prologo racconta insomma quello che
succederà l'atmosfera di tutto il brano
che non ha una storia vera che il loro
cavallo ha vissuto in calabria dove era
trasferito insieme a sopravvivere un
medico insomma estro baritono
vediamo insieme eravamo a san gimignano
esce canta quest'area era veramente
scarso il pubblico inizia a fischiare
terribilmente lui uscì dal sipario
carbonio pubblico e disse fischiate me
sentire del tenore dopo ci fu una truffa
perché questa è stata una delle prime
apparizioni nella mano in europa la
linea insomma fino a 31 anni non ero
così felice di vivere nel mondo della
musica
intanto ho incontrato quasi casualmente
la materiali sonori il produttore
giampiero bigazzi ministro terzo anno di
ragazzi nel quale mi propose di lavorare
a un cd su musiche di nino rota e
dovevamo arrangiare dei brani di in
europa e lui mi disse bisognerebbe
scrivere un brano ferito ad iniziare il
senso arriva musica 21 anni non ho mai
scritto e personale pagliacci fino a due
giorni fa
bisogna scrivere alla sera poi c'è
scritto un brano io ed allora non ho più
smesso di scrivere un museo tutti i
giorni marzo che invece di prendere il
caffellatte e ascoltare forte il
costosissimo scrivo musica e quindi ho
iniziato questo brano si chiama
buongiorno nino è il primo brano del cd
dedicato a nino rosa e oggi è stampato
in giappone in francia in messico e in
italia quindi diciamo che ho conosciuto
con giampiero ragazzi con harmonia
ensemble è un mondo totalmente diverso
da quello come sono io ho conosciuto
ambiti musicali totalmente diversi
musicisti
estremi insomma e quindi ho iniziato a
comporre magari con tutte queste questi
stimoli che venivano dall'esterno
velocemente non facevo non pensavo solo
a comporre per per per comporre avevo
bisogno di un gruppo mio di creare un
gruppo perché era un gruppo
avevo bisogno di varie di varie
opportunità comunque questo
cronologicamente è un avvenimento che
che esce un po però volevo ricordare
questa grande amicizia con carlo monni
con lui arlo e giampiero abbiamo fatto
più di 100 spettacoli in italia sulla
poesia dedicata a campana
cronologicamente questo è un po fuori ma
è comunque parallelo a questo desiderio
questa voglia di scrivere quindi questo
non è presente anche se siamo in tema è
un paese
qua dell'aretino si chiama loro
ciuffenna e in questo in questo paese io
ho proposto un laboratorio perché avevo
bisogno di creare un gruppo per eseguire
mia musa perché sono scrivere musica e
nessuno una suona insomma poco insomma
quindi cosa è successo che vedete questa
noi quattro la presidente in questo
sindaco io che sempre altissimo e
garibaldi anche se dovesse anche lui
insomma noi 46 detto va bene allora su
fen si può fare si può fare diciamo
questo laboratorio è cosa è successo che
ora tocca a voi inizio una lezioncina la
prima lezione che ho fatta dallo sul
freddo va bene allora io faccio una
domanda ora però lo so che voi siamo un
po bill essendo brevissimi qualcuno di
anche qualche discreta sennò mi veniva
troppo quindi la domanda è questa dove
vive la musica
un'ora di treno queste buone
questa volta è un'altra c'è chi ne ha di
sicuro porta nel cuore nel cuore del
credito nel quale perfetto e quello
volevo quindi nel cuore e la mente la
musa vive ora lo potete dire leone nel
tempo la musica vive nel tempo va bene
però perché la musica possa essere
scritta possa essere elaborata nello nel
tempo cioè diventa complessa diventa
difficile quindi facciamo una relazione
spazio tempo quindi questo spazio
io lo avevo chiesto per lui la strada
vagno questo spazio diventa per noi
tempo quindi questo spazio come fa a
diventare tempo con la velocità io
percorro e questo spazio diventa tempo
va bene facciamo che noi ora siamo tutti
vicino al fiume
quindi io faccio un segno
e questo può essere un fiume è giusto
fare un segno così
sì perché se siamo c'era un fiume il
fiume si sente per tutti per tutto il
tempo
come si fa a fare il fiume han dovete
fare voi così provate no fermi insieme a
me mettiamolo in questo spazio sia
quindi ci siamo di meno e quindi
abbastanza facile gestirlo insomma a
muoversi in questo spazio all'incirca
per 5 secondi
mi rimane abbastanza fatto bene quindi
parliamo
perfetto bene cielo fondo e ci siamo
benissimo poi a un certo punto inizia a
piovere bene come si fa a far la pioggia
prendete due dita e battetelo sul palmo
della mano
senti sembra sia basta facciamola
insieme quindi avete a disposizione
sulla bocca e poi questo proviamo viene
no è no e chi sbaglia ragazzo quando si
arriva la pioggia si parla di orgine non
c'è il segno ancora poniamo bene
no ragazzi qui c'è la pioggia in prima
fila poi sbagliato cioè io camera scuola
mi metto sempre in fondo perché sapevo
di quindi qua non c'era pioggia non
suoniamo proviene da capo via
bravissimi poi abbiamo a disposizione
sia etico quindi facciamo finta che
arrivano dei calciatori e si danno con i
piedi
provate senza sfondare il teatro ci
prendiamo i piedi sotto vale sono 4 di
via
perfetto abbiamo fatto musica questa è
musica va bene allora questa era la
prima lezione di musica la seconda
lezione come questa che entrano degli
strumentisti con gli strumenti ci danno
degli strumenti che bene lo vedete qua
la partitura quindi la prima lezione
la seconda si affidano al caminetto
sassi di fiume
la signora sito a sito della signora sol
minore fra e voi un la pasta troviamo
silenzio ora vediamo quello che abbiamo
fatto con degli strumenti umani e questo
strumenti fatti dall'uomo e suonare
lotteria
seconda lezione allora qua il tempo è
aleatorio se io vado un po a caso magari
sono quindici secondi però magari no poi
invece di il tempo diventa un tempo ma
questo effetto diventa un po diventa più
preciso allora questo si conta 1 2 3 4 1
2 3 4 ogni volta ce l'ha in si battevano
se io sto fermo va cha cha cha quindi
dentro di noi bisognava silenzio dentro
la nostra mente facciamo un 1 qui si
batte solamente l'uno qua si batte
lunedì 2 quasi volte il 1 2 e 3
quasi fatta in uno del 34 va bene
torniamo a farlo
1234 fascino e qui è un po come come
questa musica
torniamo allora con
siete pronti ha detto uno quanto cinema
che fanno bene solo a metà perché vai
pronti allora iniziate voi io batto
guardi io faccio
1234 voi fate questo bene tutti 12 34
votate i numeri hanno guardi bene
grazie quindi fate queste elezioni e
fate il gruppo codere dove ad esempio
vedete sono i bambini di loro un persone
allora come avete visto in questo video
sono tutti i bambini di loro ciuffenna
delle scuole perchè si fa questo
progetto in seno a garibaldi sindaco e
vele da questi ragazzi io lo faccio da
20 anni questo progetto
pensate per natale che aveva uno
strumento così piccinini chiedono uno
strumento musicale e tutti tutti suonano
insomma è logicamente loro sono tutti
delusi da questa prima luna è stato lui
questo sembra un ometto in dopo ho
guardati negli occhi gli sbirri va bene
a questo punto cosa ha detto sodano ha
detto che c'è lui è un ragazzino ma
questo veramente mio ricordo ora è un
ingegnere però continua a venire a
suonare imparato e apprezzato lo
strumento con questo con con questo
progetto insomma per sempre lo stesso di
garibaldi
va bene si va avanti
momento importante abbiamo fatto questo
incontro bellissimo fra una banda di
macedoni di zingari macedoni e la nostra
manda ecco cosa è successo che io
giampiero mi disse facciamo un disco
insieme a questo gruppo io scrissi ho
scritto tanta musica stando a roma a
portare questa musica e il loro
direttore guardò lo spartito
all'incontrario facendo anche degli
apprezzamenti quindi non nessuno leggeva
la musica e cosa dovuto fare ho dovuto
personale sta musica alla banda loro
hanno ascoltato e poi hanno riprodotto è
nato questo questo cd ulixes però
abbiamo acqua ci siamo accorti di avere
un materiale fantastico per lavande
abbiamo fatto un cd con un'asta manga
con questo cd
insomma sono successe delle cose
bellissime
ora sono le scienze forestali per occhi
ho iniziato a suonare lo strumento
insomma a bastonarmi questa cosa grazie
al progetto di ore alle scuole medie
allora ciuffi garibaldi è di verificare
i pali sito è una sera appunto dopo
qualche anno che suona con banda ero sul
divano la mia nonna fare zapping la
televisione e dopo un po agire ci
lanceremo a nulla sento questa musica a
raidue con one ma questa è la musica
della banda meravigliati che a
telefonare a tutti c'è la musica della
banda r2 l'avevano scelta per questo
programma e skalibur che però poi
purtroppo è durato tre puntate però è
stata una bella supernova la bella
soddisfazione le stesse questa è una
un'altra dimostrazione di quanto quel cd
è stato importante per noi questa è una
delle bande più preparate al mondo sono
tutti i professionisti e la banda reale
del belgio e durante una serata di gala
hanno fatto giungere a ma verdi dell'iri
e chiesero c'è scritto musicisti morti
ma italiani e chiesero un brano a me per
poter inserire un brano contemporaneo
puntano in questa serata di gala se fa
questo montaggio
il solito ci casca rispetto in cina va
bene
no scherzi e questo tutte le nostre
collaborazioni sono cose importanti per
una banda noi siamo domanda ad un paese
la dei dati presepe no diciamo la banda
di un piccolo e abbiamo fatto tutte
queste collaborazioni
questo solo per capire quanto ambiti
diversi poi possono un po influenzare un
po di tutti e far crescere siamo avanti
ecco
abbiamo sentito io mi chiamo giovanni
papini che sono un ex generale degli
alpini e ora mi sono ridotto a suonare
il trombone colorio qui eravamo alla
leopolda di firenze abbiamo fatto un
concerto con una bellissima banda di
santiago di cuba la panda municipale di
santiago di cuba gente che suonava
meravigliosamente c'era un pubblico di
circa 5.000 persone e si vede che la
nostra musica è piaciuta perché a un
certo punto si è sviluppata una grande
paga la gente che saltava gente che
ballava gente che urlava un polverone
terrificante è stata veramente una
serata meravigliosa da riposare
ecco questo è una delle ultime
collaborazioni alessandro benvenuti
abbiamo fatto stato impiegato di vista
de andrè siamo delle mentre al ferri di
maggior leggeri
unanime alla gente
un po di tempo era un po cambiando ma no
nel verde
io da un pò di me
non l amore
buonasera a tutti io mi chiamo che lei
da camiciotti e sono la presidente della
filarmonica questo concerto a milano mi
sono segnate alcune cose sono rimasta
per sistemare alcune faccende
burocratiche la mattina seguente
ho letto sul corriere della sera a
queste parole la filarmonica giuseppe
verdi di loro ciuffenna nell'aretino
diretta dal clarinettista e compositore
ori odori ha fatto centro con una
performance potente visionaria
musicalmente impeccabile la vostra
presidente siamo alla fine l'ultima
diciamo ciliegina per noi insomma davide
ferrario chiamo resiste molto attento
alle musiche ha preso un nostro brano
per commentare una scena volta
importante del film in ungheria malgrado
i nomi impossibili
ci sentivamo ormai in europa sotto l'ala
di una civiltà che era la nostra a
riparo dall armante apparizioni quali
quella del cammello in moldavia
ciao
no
mamma
grazie